foreign
[Music]
what is up this is the Ramsey Show
broadcasting from the PODS moving in
storage Studio here in Franklin
Tennessee it's a show where America
hangs out to have a conversation about
your money your life your work your
relationships your mental health
anything that's going on in your life
we're here to talk to you about it the
call is toll-free triple eight eight two
five five two two five I'm John deloney
joined here by best-selling author and
good friend Ken Coleman and we're
talking about relationships life work
whatever's going on in your life give us
a buzz triple eight eight two five five
two two five hey Ken yes sir uh I heard
you just finished walked out on your
show uh that sounded bad you didn't walk
out on your show you just finished up
yeah and walked in
um yeah wrapped up is much better that's
what we were talking about today I know
you like that oh yeah I wanted to I
heard you announced this and I wanted I
was like man tell me about this why
working hard won't help you be
successful it was a little bit of a a
play on words here but we wanted to to
kind of focus on this obsessive hustle
culture that you and I see on social
media and there's a lot of influencers
on social media have a lot more
followers than you and I let me be very
fair who preach hustle hustle hustle
I'll sleep when I die work hard work
hard work hard work hard and first of
all you and I both are fans of hard work
but what I was saying today we kind of
let off with hard work in and of itself
just I'm gonna work hard there's no
guarantee for Success no at all right
and what it could do is actually burn
you out faster harder and leave you in a
place where you are completely confused
and frustrated and so you and I I mean
you know famed psychologist mihai cheek
sent me high oh yeah I practice that
name many many times to be able to say
it I believe he's done I believe he's
Hungarian but he is well known as you
know uh as the father of flow and flow
is a term that he used to describe what
I teach on the Ken Coleman show I call
it being in the sweet spot but he
actually coined the term flow because of
the distinct characteristics that he
found in 30 plus years of research what
it feels like looks like
to experience flow in your work and he
compared it to a true form of ecstasy a
mental ecstasy and so we talked about
that today which is and it's about what
I said was that working hard
is actually not the focus the focus
ought to be to work smart and we've
heard the phrase work smart not hard and
I actually do believe that but what I
said was and I want to know your
thoughts on this that when we work smart
in other words
get in our unique sweet spot as I teach
using Talent what you do best to perform
passion work you love to then produce
results that you care deeply about now
all of a sudden I'm working smart and as
a result the effort
comes along with it well in efforts
towards a thing it's not just effort you
have to worry about working hard when
you're doing this thing that you care
deeply about it's the point it just
happens in fact you just have people
pull you out of that work so you can do
your other things like you have a family
that's right and so uh we went through
and and I'll give this to you because
you can look at it he said those were
the eight characteristics and it's
really fascinating
yeah like he actually studied it yeah
and those are those characteristics so
we unpacked that on the show so I
stumbled across
um
man if a great resource is the the two
guys at um the minimal Revolution oh
yeah uh they're extraordinary uh is that
what it is our minimalist friends no not
the minimalist
um
James will you check that out it's the
minimal Revolution
um it's not the mineral resolution and I
check it every single day anyway these
are two
um economists who are very thoughtful
and
with the incoming AIS AI begins to
transform the workspace over the next 10
or 15 years artificial um learning
machine learning
they note if your whole idea whole
identity is based on how hard you work
on just hustling grinding and grinding
and grinding when a machine can go 24 7
365 with no breaks you lose good luck
good luck right so if your whole
identity and we all want to be Rudy like
we all see yourself as Underdog we're
gonna be rooting sure but Rudy is
working towards a thing right towards a
passion and his whole identity wasn't it
was in I'm gonna serve the team right
and I'll keep showing up and keep
showing up here's what I want you to
comment on because you deal with this I
mean this is square in your lane is your
your is the mental and emotional
relationship health
John I see people working towards status
yeah oh gosh and so like we show up at
picnics or soccer games or whatever and
when our feels like all of our
conversations and I'm chief on this
Chief Center on this if I'm not careful
it's we start talking how you doing it's
like I'm so busy and then all of a
sudden it's a competition for how busy
we are and I I just feel like the busy
culture is killing our souls what are
your thoughts it's it's a strange world
we found ourselves in where we're not
judged on our uh when we're not judged
on our output on what we're actually put
under the world we're judged on well did
you work hard how is your effort and
that has turned into yeah well I'm
putting more effort than you are yeah I
am effort King oh yeah I'm effort King
I've been there too man how's work man
it's just busy life's busy oh yeah I'm
really busy too right what a dumb way to
interact with another person we've made
our self-worth about how hard we work
yeah and it comes in from the first in
last out right of course that was the
80s and 90s if you'd be the first one
into the last one to leave right and
that turned into the cap social like the
work capitalist butts and butts and
seats that's right right yeah and you
lose the person who's making connections
who's actually making calls going on
visiting people doing doing good work
man and you and I share this we share
this effect we we do this at our
Building Wealth events we kind of take
questions from the crowd on this but you
know what I'm trying to teach on the Ken
Coleman show as a part of Ramsey when we
talk about you know money and life
excuse me life through the lens of money
relationships and work it's that
success is the wrong metric right
significance is the metric and what I
mean by this is every human is
significant just by being a human right
but your War contribution it's it's
about what is significant to you the
school teacher is just as successful as
the President of the United States right
right because in her world this is what
she wants to be doing and she's able to
provide and and fill in the blank it's
results mission
in its heart passion based and so if we
can get to the point and what I'm trying
to do is just help people see what's
your unique contribution that matters to
you because you see how it matters to
others and that purpose isn't about us
hey here's here's what's important when
you when you're defining what's
important to you yeah it's also
important to create a world where that
is okay
it's not a great point we run and this
is the show exists because people say I
want to be a teacher yep I was put on
Earth to be a teacher but I'm driving a
Lexus
and sometimes Alexis car doesn't fit
with a teacher's salary that's right
it's the teachers who say no I want to
be a teacher I'm a Corolla person yep
and I'm going to look up in 38 years I'm
gonna be one of I'm going to be a
Millionaire right because I created a
world where my dream could exist and by
the way to your point they are the third
largest group of net worth millionaires
according to the Ramsey solution study
of over 10 000 Edward millionaire so you
know I'm really trying to drive this
because we're more than ever we need
boundaries man it's what you're helping
us with and you and I combine on that
redefining what work is yeah and what if
your identity is oh just outwork you
cool man A robot's coming wow get
yourself a good counselor and a good
doctor because you're gonna need it but
if you're yeah good a good a good heart
surgeon but if your philosophy is I'm
gonna find purpose I'm gonna find
meaning I'm gonna work hard to get there
now you're onto something
[Music]
thank you
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
I don't know why I said that it's the
marginal Revolution with Tyler Cowan and
Alex
um it's just a it's a new source a Blog
source that I go to just a couple of
great thinkers who have some provocative
ideas on things don't agree with them on
everything but I do love their informed
opinion marginal Revolution but we all
need more margin I mean if you just go
down the list so you just turned me on
to him folks he was going nuts on the in
the break talking about them and you
daily digest these every single day
that's where I get my news do I get my
news I love it it's fantastic I'm gonna
do it all right let's go to Susan in San
Antonio hey Susan what's up
good afternoon thank you for taking my
call you got it what's up how can we
help
so basically I've been in the medical
field for 30 years and back when right
before covet hit I started out on a
venture to open a day hab for nlsfully
disabled adults and we were going fine
but then cover hit and everything shut
down and since then it's pretty much
been stagnant because I've put in the
501c3 been waiting on funding can't get
the funding so I'm going to just throw
it to the walls and start it up in
January
I don't know if that's a good idea or
not I just need somebody from an upright
source to go yeah and walk me through
the steps that I'm not crazy to go ahead
and go from a full-time job to a
part-time job and take this on as a
full-time Venture all right well let's
just let's stay in the level of
uncertainty that you just presented
what are you uncertain about to where
you feel you need to call to other
people and get their opinion so is this
a good idea what are you concerned about
that might be a bad idea
the biggest concern I have is that when
I started this Venture it was basically
from my heart and I was doing it for
free and hoping that getting it going
doing it part time and for free that
eventually we would get funding we would
get clients that would start paying and
things would move on now I'm looking at
going into this and trying to get paying
clients immediately
um not a ton of them just a handful of
them to get started and hoping that that
will bring the universe together to get
the 501c finally off of some government
desk that we can then go after the grant
money that is sitting there so are you
financially independent or in a position
or you can go without income for six
months to a year
I can go for or I gotta fully funded
emergency fund of of five months but
that's for emergency I'm I'm totally
debt free if I keep my part-time job I
can financially make it for my expenses
that I have currently so you have a
part-time job that you think will keep
you afloat and not make you dip into the
emergency fund which I want to stipulate
emergencies are not
emergency funds are not to be used as a
bridge fund to start a venture so
correct and I I truly believe I work
full-time now I have been very frugal
and I've made myself to the point where
what I'm making would be covering my
monthly expenses all right well Susan
with some extra uh here's what I wanted
to ask that question because I wanted to
see where your mindset was but I got to
tell you if I were your son or your
brother or your close friend
uh and I would not be true to to who I
am as a professional to give you advice
to do this this is doubling down on what
has not been a successful bet so far
and it's not wise
and I think that it could put you in a
really tough situation uh financially
emotionally mentally I'll let John
comment on what could be the downfall of
this but this what I get most concerned
about is someone turning a dream into a
nightmare because they didn't wait long
enough they didn't do it the right way
in a dream which this is a dream and
your heart is so good uh and and this is
coming from a wonderful place
what doesn't it doesn't remove passion
doesn't remove the need to have common
sense and to test things and try things
and scale and and kind of take your time
with it starting small and growing slow
and I think you're frustrated and I
understand why you're frustrated but uh
I I would just tell you those are all of
the reasons John why this is a big red
flag to say no do not move from the
full-time job and go all in and push
your chips in the middle of the table
right now I don't think it's wise yeah
Susan belief doesn't override math and
when you say I believe this will work
out
that scares me to death I I want you to
know and I want you to have some
spreadsheets and some here's what this
is going to cost and here's my marketing
expenses and here's what my
um here's what my tax bill will be and
here's how many paying customers I need
to get through month one and month two
you're going to find yourself with zero
emergency fund left you're going to be
even more down than you are right now
and the bigger problem is is you're
going to be wondering why the universe
didn't show up for you because you put
all this good into the world
um I had a counseling Professor tell me
something once and the way she said it
I didn't get how profound it was until I
was thinking about it later that night
you can help people and charge them
money
and we have this idea that if you are in
the helping profession that especially
mental health profession especially
helping those on the margins those are
special needs
that you should basically do it for free
or you shouldn't charge any money do you
have that sense because I get that that
you are trying to do these things for
free because you want to help people out
the least of these
and what's happening is you're
sacrificing yourself and your ability to
run a business and you're going to end
up crashing everybody at that time do
you feel that Susan or am I off
part of it yes the other part of it is
that um
here in the communities that I live in
because I don't actually live in San
Antonio that's south of it we have no no
resources for these intellectually
disabled adults okay
um and I'm trying to model it after some
very successful
um
companies that have started where
basically they give these guys a job we
come in and say the job is making paper
just to make it simple that everybody
has a hand in making this paper and then
we sell it and they get a paycheck and
we get some profits off of making the
paper that's right and that's you know
I'm starting Grassroots because we don't
have anything like it in our community
or even within a 50 mile radius of where
we are so Susan let me ask you a quick
question on that because I I think right
now my advice to you is to turn some
rejection into redirection so instead of
doing it yourself right now and I know
you say there's no resources so let me
pull back a little bit so in your
community you're saying there's not even
some local County Municipal state
government services and it may not be
doing what you want to do but they are
at least serving those adults would that
be that would be true there's somebody
that's serving these adults but maybe
not the way you want to is that true
false
it's more On The Floss side because they
have very they only accept a handful of
clients and only the very severe clients
right so you want to help the Gap right
those in the middle that don't qualify
for exceptional services but that can't
just walk up and
go get a job on their own
correct they they basically are latchkey
adults that have no supervision but they
don't have the mental capacity to take
care of themselves without something
here's where I'm trying to so so they're
but there you need to go to the pockets
in your community that are aware of
these adults and are serving them maybe
in a different way than you want to
here's the I want to give you a
practical encouragement Susan
um I still want you to stay in your
full-time day job but I want you to say
all right instead of trying to do it all
myself I'm going to go and see if I can
connect some needs together so I want
you to think here's an exercise a
homework exercise for you to
think of jobs that are open right now
that are having a heart that companies
are having time filling because it's
happening so it could be everything from
fast food restaurants to the Home
Improvement store whatever who needs to
hire and they're having a hard time who
are the leaders over there and then who
are the families over here and how can I
connect the two I think this was more of
an activist role to give this another
calibration another way to love it so
instead of having to have all the
overhead come up with the products what
you are is you become a resource coach
and then learn how to turn it into a
business once I actually make it happen
and you promise these people who are
going to hire them all walk alongside
these these clients I'll make sure
they're doing good work and they're
taking care of business and now now
you're helping these folks right in a
way that's not going to cost you
everything thanks for your heart man we
need more people like you out in the
community Susan we'll be right back on
the Ramsay show thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five I'm
John deloney joined here by my good
friend Ken Coleman and we're taking your
calls on money life work mental health
whatever's going on Triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go out
to Terence in Cleveland Ohio what's up
Terence
how you doing good how are you man
I've done better I get in there oh man
what's up
so I'm currently faced with the idea of
Silent bankruptcy
um I currently have about 70 000 in debt
I make about 20 000 a year I've been
working for about a year now I was in a
nursing home for a year before that and
um as of now I just had a recent
uh bad incident my car was stolen back
in August and um with the repairs I've
defaulted on my uh car note I actually
got two months deferred already and now
I have to pay a large deductible to get
it from the mechanic and I'm still you
know faced with the uh with the car
payments
which is more than half of my monthly
income right now and I've been
considering following chapter seven to
remove a lot of my debts and try to
start over because it's to the point
where I'm not able to save anything at
the end of the month yeah Terence can I
ask you what are you doing for a job
right now
I'm a custodian okay and did you did I
hear you right you're making about 20
000.
yeah okay and then you said you were did
I hear you say you were in a nursing
home
I was yeah okay do you have any physical
limitations right now that would uh keep
you from doing any other type of work
than being a custodian
well I have heart disease
um minor neurological deficiencies like
my endurance is very low okay I have to
expend my energy twice as much to do
normal functions is the custodial job I
don't want to assume but is it a
physical job obviously on your feet a
lot and doing a lot of physical labor
I mean yeah but I work in my own pace I
got employed through this organization
called vocational guidance and it's
pretty much geared towards disabled
persons like myself okay uh another
couple quick questions here
um
how much how much do you owe to get that
car from the mechanic what would be the
fee you got to pay to get it back
one thousand dollars a thousand dollars
and what would you say the car is worth
versus what you owe on it
it's worth about 20 and uh
I'm sorry you broke up you owe what
35
000 and the car is only worth about 20
000. okay all right
uh
the the reason I went that direction
John and Terence the reason I'm asking
you about what you're doing what your
physical limitations are
um is because I even though you have
limitations and I know you went through
an organization that's trying to help
you out
man I I'm willing to stake my entire
name and reputation on the fact that you
should be making and you can be making
way more than twenty thousand which
would help us in this financial
situation to come up with a thousand
dollars to get the car then we could
sell the car uh get a smaller loan it's
the only time we recommend loans uh
maybe from a credit union and to pay off
the rest of the loan and then start
fresh but one of the things we've got to
do is get you into a place where you can
make more income but not have all the
physical exertion because you do have
some physical limitations and and I want
to try to help you on that we may not be
able to solve it all on this call but I
at least want to put that out to you so
that you have a mindset that you don't
have to look at chapter seven to get out
of this mess do you understand what I'm
saying I know you feel like that's the
only option you have left
how does that hit you how do you push
back if there's some pushback something
that John and I don't know
it's been a very depressing you know
dealing with it all and I never even
considered filing bankruptcy ever in my
life sure so Terence uh filing for
bankruptcy if we look at the data
um
has a lot of external consequences
besides money and you're feeling it
right now right it feels like it's going
to be this big freedom in this big
release and there is a release to it but
man
what it does to your psyche what it does
to your ability to navigate certain
things moving forward it's just such a
burden it's it's it's very similar to
divorce I'll never recommend somebody
get divorced that's a decision someone's
got to make on their own and I don't
ever recommend that somebody file for
bankruptcy simply because I know the
downstream consequences are so heavy
sometimes it's your only option Dave's
talked about it he's he did it
um and he is probably one of the last in
lines to say hey he went and developed a
plan so that nobody ever has to go
through that right
um
I've spent my career up until I I joined
Ramsey Solutions working with
people with learning exceptionalities
and with special needs
did they Place does this agency place
you in a place where they said this is
all you can do
because right now when I look at the
wages even at minimum wage places
um are paying double minimum wage in
certain places they're paying a lot more
than twenty thousand dollars a year to
work fast food right now or to drive
Uber and I'm thinking I'm trying to
think of a couple of places that you
could work and then get another job
driving around where you could just
listen to music or listen to podcasts or
talk on the phone and if you have those
days where you're just
worn out
you can stay at home you don't have to
work that shift if it's Uber if it's
ubereats or if it's one of those you
know Lyft or anything like that
my question for you is this
instead of
um just saying all I'm ever going to do
is be able to do twenty thousand dollars
a year do you have a mentor or friend or
someone who will walk alongside you
that's outside of the agency that you
trust that you said hey we got a figure
I got to make more money and I need your
help looking at jobs applying for jobs
going to interview with jobs would you
be willing to walk alongside is there
somebody else that would help you with
that or is the agency all you got
not at the moment I think they're
literally all I have right now I haven't
um
even considered you know
you're trying to find other
um
like people of that kind of bird to talk
to okay well Terence I I want to
challenge you on something because I
John and I know you can get out of this
I know you can and we want you to borrow
our belief if you just got John and I
today I'm telling you Terence yes you
have the physical limitations but John
is right we're talking Walmart and and
Target late shift McDonald's you can
make as much as 18 20 22 dollars an hour
not only that
um Kroger just announced I don't know if
you had but I'm giving you ideas to
where you go wait a second the world is
much bigger than this agency just
placing me somewhere where they have a
relationship because more money changes
your life dramatically am I right or am
I wrong
you're right I mean I want you just for
a second to imagine making twenty
dollars an hour
how would that change your life
I wouldn't worry so much come on man
you'll be able to get that car out of
the mechanic pretty quick
and and John's right I mean that what
people are paying listen and can I tell
you this I want to paint a bigger
picture
Walmart Target just two big companies
they are also giving tuition
reimbursement to where not only you work
and making more money you could take the
next chapter in your life and get
qualified for something and they're
going to reimburse you so you got to
know there are more possibilities for
you and you can get the car out of the
mechanic and you can pay the debt off
you can walk through this and we're
going to walk through this with you
let's let's give you Financial Peace
University we're going to gift you a
full year of that and I want to give you
the book uh Dave's block he sold six
million copies something like that and
Counting Total Money Makeover if I give
that to you will you promise to read it
yes I do do you believe Terence that you
can come out of this
yeah
I
let me take one step myself let me take
one step below what Ken's saying
you've been told you're less than
haven't you
I have ever since I got sick and
suffered a traumatic brain injury and
all of that stuff yeah that's right
you've been told she's been very shocked
you've been told you're broken you've
been told you're less than you've been
told you go over there and Ken and I are
both calling bull crap on that we
believe in you more than you do and I
want you to believe in yourself as much
as Ken and I do
stay on the line we're going to get you
these tools in hand and man trust us
there is light on the other side of this
thing now we're so proud of you brother
somebody needs you to show up and be the
best version of Terence that the world
has ever seen that's where we want you
to get to
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Wealth live event has been such a hit
this fall and selling out all across the
country that today we're announcing new
spring tour dates that's right you can
join Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz George
Campbell Dr John deloney and Ken Coleman
in Indianapolis on a February 16th
Austin on February 23rd in Anaheim
California on May 2nd
despite what you hear or see on the news
and internet Building Wealth is still
possible we'll walk you through a simple
but proven plan so you can build lasting
wealth and reach your financial goals
don't wait to reserve your spot we only
have 200 VIP tickets available for these
events that include a meet and greet
with Dave and the rest of the gang recap
of tour dates Indianapolis February 16th
Austin February 23rd Anaheim May 2nd
Building Wealth live tickets start at 39
bucks and they're going to sell out fast
go to ramseysolutions.com
events to reserve your seat today all
right let's go to Sonya in Austin Texas
what's up Sonia
hi there hi there what's up
um okay so I
so I'm in I'm in the process of doing
the seven baby steps and I've completed
baby step number three but I'm kind of
stuck
um I'm not sure if I should be investing
oh it is the next step but I'm not sure
um if I should be investing or if I
should I'm current we're currently uh
saving up for a house
so I don't know if I should put all our
money into like saving for a house
or start the baby step number four while
saving up for the house so we actually
after years of listening to folks
walking this plan we actually created
step 3B or 3.5 and it is somebody in
your situation who wants to do a Sprint
to save up for the down payment of their
home they're gonna pause everything and
take 18 months uh 24 months and knock
out a down payment we're gonna put
everything towards it we're gonna crush
it and go get it and then once we get
that down payment we're gonna settle
into steps four five and six
got it okay and then um also
where like what is the what's the best
place to finance a mortgage loan would
it be like through my bank that I've
been with him for like over 10 years or
like a credit union
my most recent transaction was with
Churchill Mortgage that's who we have
recommended for years and years and
years and
um I'll tell you this my experience with
Churchill was here was my first
conversation uh with my mortgage broker
he said I refuse to let you do a deal
that's going to not be in your best
financial interest he was he said I'm
not going to take your money if it's not
going to help you and your family out
that's how they started the conversation
with me
um so I've got high trust in them
um
that's where I would start at Churchill
Mortgage
okay sounds good and then the 20 percent
is also what y'all are recommending
between 10 and 20 yeah between 10 and 20
yeah I know in some markets like Austin
has just lost its mind the last few
years
um 10 would be the bare minimum 20 get
you in without having to pay PMI which
is just a pain watching your money go to
somebody else's to secure somebody
else's loan right
got it yeah so Sonia I wanted to get
some real-time uh data from you if you
don't mind what what housing prices
doing right now in Austin
oh there's through the roof oh still
going up not coming down at all yeah no
not at all wow how far along are you to
the down payment that you want
um we currently have 18 000 saved and
we're trying to look into saving 50 to
60k
um for that we're trying to do the 20
down payment great so if you if you just
hit the gas you'll put everything
towards it you worked extra jobs how
quickly could y'all knock that out
um so I'm a travel nurse so my my so
three weeks
no kidding uh now we were thinking about
a year and before we can hit that 60 000
Mark hopefully do you have little ones
in the house yeah I do have a one and a
half year old okay so yeah y'all figure
out how we're gonna make this work for a
year and as a travel nurse you could go
make some bank and just save it all and
really get into a place there uh and get
yourself set up nicely down the road
it's fantastic
yeah okay sounds good well thank you
yeah way to go Sonia that's impressive
yes
awesome thank you so much guys oh you
got it you got it
um Ken when you guys were
how'd y'all how did you guys as your
family manage 3B
well 3B for us was a little bit
different than the traditional all right
we because we were we had already been
debt free in our home in Atlanta okay
guys so then when we sold and moved up
just a matter of moving it over it was a
function of taking that Equity gotcha we
still rented for two years and I tell
people this all the time it was less
about the money at the time it was more
about what's the right location where
are we going to be and when you got
three little ones we had let's see Ty
would have been third grade Chase first
grade and Josie was a kindergartner so
it was like let's rent uh for at least a
year and figure out where in Middle
Tennessee do we want to land and it
ended up turning into two years for
saving so it was a kind of a hybrid 3B
and uh and then we found the right place
and and we're able to move into that so
it's hard for folks to wait
um but I gotta tell you for us uh
waiting two years and renting I don't
look at that as throwing money away it
was a huge decision for us uh
financially as well as just I don't know
what uh geographically it just allowed
us to to lock into the right place
because we knew we were going to be here
a long time that's awesome all right
let's go to Nelson in Atlanta let's see
here hey what's up Nelson
hi good morning good afternoon
yeah we can hear you what's up man
okay here's the situation uh opportunity
to refine uh if you want me to mix in a
company
they say they would uh pay off all my
credit card debt which is around 45 50
000 uh pay off my truck so I'm gonna pay
off my second mortgage and all when I
was a mortgage the interest rate would
go up to 6.7 pounds from four uh the uh
we'll say the payment Nelson Nelson
Nelson yes sir
terrible terrible idea someone is using
the skin off of your butt to put money
in their wallet
don't do it don't do it don't do it
you're gonna make a a list of your debts
and smallest to largest and you're gonna
probably have to go for a walk around
the neighborhood and weep a little bit
and then you're gonna get after it yeah
there's not a shortcut or a hack through
it man please don't do this I'll talk to
someone
Chris about 20 000. good it's over 100
000 a year
and uh Social Security and everything
that'll help me out good well I'll be
asked for this
I hate Nelson talking to the phone
please
I'm using a company that's helping me it
gives me legal protection do I have to
worry about legal protection with these
credit card companies pay your bills man
yeah no you don't
no pay your bills
okay well I really appreciate it if you
join the public don't hang up yet if you
join one of these refi companies what
they tell you is don't pay your bills
anymore
don't pay your bills we'll take care of
it from here you just sent us a big
chunk of money and we'll take care of
all this stuff
um I did that once what a nightmare
I screwed up everything don't do it it's
almost like a rank it's almost like a
bankruptcy don't do it don't do it it's
actually all marketing language you know
I've heard Dave describe it this way
it's like moving your pile of debt from
one part of the yard to the other part
of the yard right it's still debt I want
to just get real practical here for a
second on two things number one you
don't need legal protection from the
credit card company what you need to do
is is get as John said very serious and
say I'm going to tackle this thing and
the baby steps will help you do it and
so you take the smallest debt of all of
the debts I wrote down you hit 45 to 50K
in credit card debt you have a truck and
a second mortgage what's the what's the
debt on the truck
uh I think it's like 30 something maybe
what what's the truck worth paid off a
second vehicle almost a 2018 Ford F-150
so it's got about 70 000 miles on it I
didn't ask you that I'm just saying how
much is it worth
a worth
I mean selling it I don't know I'm
looking for low 50s right now it's about
45 000 bucks all right so if John's
right and he usually is I'm selling that
truck and I'm gonna go get myself an
older truck you can get a fine truck for
15 000. boom we just knocked out thirty
thousand dollars in debt then you call
the credit card companies up and you go
hey here's the deal I am going to pay
you back you don't worry about any
harassing phone calls you start paying
it off get really serious about knocking
those credit cards out and you'll get
there don't look for a hacks when it
comes to nutrition working out your
money don't your relationship don't look
for hacks go right through the middle of
it you can do this
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18 million people
Peter you go to ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your life your work
your relationships and your money what
is up I'm John deloney joined here by
Ken Coleman and we're taking your calls
on everything triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to Mary
in Providence Rhode Island what's up
Mary
hi I'm John it's on my spaniano to you
all
um I I guess my question it's it's both
career-wise but I guess it would be on
your end of the spectrum too of like
emotionalize is I'm 33 years old and I
just can't seem to find a career and I
feel very directionalized and I'm trying
to just get some advice I feel like I've
always been the type that like when I
was younger I would you know like I had
a plan I had a correction and then I
graduated and then now I'm like
I'm looking for 10 years since I
graduate and I still don't feel like I
have a career path so I don't I'm just
looking for some Direction with that
what was your direction when you were
younger
uh I well I originally wanted to be a
journalist wow that was my first major
because I wanted to like help people I
wanted to write stories that brought
light to issues that people had and like
you know help really other people to
come to action interesting what changed
um I had my first internship in
journalism and I realized I was like
this this profession will kill me I knew
I wanted to have a family I was like
it's not sustainable and I don't want to
always be traveling and leaving my
family and having crazy hours so it was
just kind of like the feeding okay this
is where we gotta go back to the story
so I already put you on rewind now we
want to press pause you cool with this
yeah all right so this happens to a lot
of people you you have a pretty clear uh
you can't Define it or articulate it but
you have a clear Direction you go and
it's not what you expected or parts of
it were what you expected and then the
schedule and the grueling hours and the
travel and the not glamorous pay because
journalism doesn't pay much at all it's
awful
yeah and all of that crashed into your
heart the reality crashed in your heart
and you were left defeated was the word
you used it's the right word and so
because you were defeated
you then became confused and since that
day yeah and since that day you've been
like that Tumbleweed in those western
movies you know that just kind of blows
around before a penultimate scene a
shootout and it's just like you're
they're letting the wind blow you back
and forth and so here so here
and that's pretty much like
but I know and I got great news for you
the answer for direction and Clarity is
to go back
to where we are right now so
let's go back to the answer you gave
about what you loved about journalism or
what you thought was going to be great
about it and it was I'm going to repeat
to the best of my memory but you go
there with me it was storytelling
using words research investigating
advocating for the general public
information is good and I can take
information that you need to know and I
can use it for your good to protect you
to inform you does that sound about
right that's what really got you fired
up about it yeah I think mostly to just
the helping of people that's the one
thing that I I feel like that even
though I've been like a tumble leader
you said during my career I love to help
people that's the thing that really
brings me joy okay great so with that in
mind there was the storytelling in the
informing the advocating you agree with
that part as I described it that way
all right all right then let's shift so
so so so this is fine so right now I
want you to describe the people you
would most love to help forget the job
description forget where you're doing it
I pay you the money you want to make and
you just get to help people I hand you a
check and I say Mary all you got to do
to get this checked the next two weeks
is to go keep helping these people who
are the people that come to mind right
now describe
um children
um people who are like impoverished
impoverished they're like they come from
like poor backgrounds
great all right now in your own that's
awesome now in your own words don't
worry about it sounding pretty just John
and I here forget everybody else
describe the problem the source of the
impover the poverty that you want to
help fix what's the problem is you see
it
as far as uh like poverty a lot of it
sometimes is education mindset
uh just
um
like if people aren't from a family
where there's been like substance abuse
things like that I can be part of the
party excellent excellent
and now the solution to that problem
that you would want to be a part of
no I know it's a big problem but stop no
here knew what you just did you went
from feeling to thinking on me and I get
it and I know you're nervous and I'm not
trying to put you on the spot but your
heart's got the answer it's right there
you're two-thirds of the way through
this formula
in your own words feel the answer how
would you what would be a solution that
you could get excited about to that
education problem with substance issues
or what what would what would be
something you could get excited about an
organization or you see a solution in
the world that's helping those people
that you so beautifully describe say it
oh I feel like sometimes non-profits
because that's really what I originally
want to do when I left College was I
wanted to work for a non-profit I'm not
really sure like I know there's
non-profits like um oh my God the name
is looking right now where they help
Dress for Success like something like
that great okay like a dress for success
type of program fantastic
so we started off this phone call with
you going I have no idea I'm just
wandering and now we've gotten to some
pretty good Clarity so here's the
homework assignment for you okay and I
want to give John a chance to kind of
speak to your emotions and what you're
dealing with
very simply before you go to bed tonight
I want you to go on the internet in your
area and look at all the non-profits or
government local institutions that are
serving those kids you know who those
kids are
so who's serving them all right now we
have a list
what jobs are available or posted within
all of those organizations and based on
your education and vast experience what
seems to be a really good fit for you in
that you have the skill and experience
and it matches up with the kind of work
you want to do that's the homework
assignment just to see what's out there
I love it
so well I have to because I need to find
a job I don't have a job there you go
all right so Ken gave you some
incredible practical tips I want to give
you
um a 30 000 foot view is that cool
okay you sound like you are somebody I
would call and I'm just making this up
you're a finish liner
your life is about goals and completing
the goal correct
yeah and I don't feel like I've
completed anything no no here's the
problem when you're a finish liner when
your life is a series of goals
you complete the goal you run the
marathon you get the degree then you go
back to and get a master's degree here's
the worst part about completing a goal
you go with you
you cross that finish line and so every
time you get that new job you show up
and you don't like you so let's shift
from being a Finish Line or two back out
ask yourself who do I want to be and as
Ken asked who do I want to help what do
I want to put into the world and we're
gonna go make that happen and the goals
will follow along with your new identity
this is the Ramsey Show we'll be right
back
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismanage or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use promo code Ramsay to get the best
deal
today's question comes from DJ in New
York I'm 31 years old and have cerebral
palsy due to my disability I've had many
health and education challenges
throughout my life I want to work with
other people with disabilities such as
autism
such as autism as a registered Behavior
technician or a board-certified behavior
analyst but with my own challenges I
cannot attend school for higher
education in this area I'm trying to
find other options or certifications
like life coaching that would allow me
to do this work but I'm feeling defeated
how can I stop thinking that I'm not
good enough or that I'm running out of
time to accomplish my dreams you two are
my favorite Ramsay personalities oh wow
did you set me up on that thanks James
we're grateful you put that that can't
be real look I'm I've literally just had
my own Ron Burgundy moment I was reading
that real time I would have skipped that
that sounds awful did you put that in
there
well it was actually this was actually
for you and George but I'll take it yeah
all right so now I'm sorry DJ all right
I don't know well it would be great if I
read this ahead of time
um
a lot here John yeah
um you've got some technical stuff but
there's more emotional there than there
is technical let you go on emotions I
think mindset helps if this was a call
to my show I literally would say you
need to talk to I want you to spend some
time with a mental health counselor to
get you to a place where I can help you
because that mindset of worth and value
has to be right-sided so that we can
then go that's you right you are
valuable
then I can help you come up with how you
can give but I feel a lot of this I've
had this call before so what do you say
what DJ's got to do is to balance what I
love and what I want and what my purpose
is you know we're just talking about
this off air right this is who I want to
help I've been through this I got a
lived experience and this is who I want
to help and then this is the boundaries
of the game so whenever I think of this
I think of
um I just lost his name the guy Golden
State Warriors
the star yes Steph Curry Steph Curry
loves the game of basketball I want to
win basketball games
and I'm five nine or however tall he is
yeah so he had to create a new way to
get on that field or get on the court
and so he became the best three-point
shooter of all time and he's his
practice is legendary his work ethic and
all that so DJ has there's a path
towards helping folks and it looks like
going to college getting a graduate
degree getting certified and now you've
seen an influx over the last 20 years of
life coaches folks who are getting
trained on how to listen and how to
encourage and how to ask good questions
it becomes okay I want to do this this
particular path may not be available
that's correct I'm not 6 10. I'm not
going to be a the traditional power
forward so what can I do what's another
way to get on the field or to change the
game altogether and so it becomes the
defeated comes from I see this path and
I I don't feel like I can participate on
this path
and you can flip that around and say
cool I'm heading off and I'm creating A
New Path and the way you do that that's
a great great point and I'll just jump
right in there practically what we do is
we stop focusing on the position and we
focus on the people there you go so the
positions here are registered Behavior
technician or a board certified behavior
analyst now it's great to look into
things like that and have a very
specific Target but as John just so
beautifully laid out DJ you've
acknowledged there are limits where
those aren't options so while I
understand how disappointing that is
we've got a guard against disappointment
turning into discouragement right and
depression it's a fact there's a period
at the end now what now we grieve it yep
absolutely but now let's go okay wait a
second and instead of focusing on those
two positions you focus on the people
you want to help and so you go okay
where can I help those people that don't
require a college degree or don't cause
you know don't require limitations but
you also mentioned in here to too is
something to do with your area
so you know what would have to be true
for me to change my geography
to then be able to do it so instead of
focusing on the limitations and I as
cheesy as this sounds in my head right
now you must focus on other
possibilities that's right and so what
if uh here's what guides me when I'm
sitting down writing a new book and I'm
thinking about a program and I'm
thinking about
what's the thing that is driving me the
most famous where are my what's the pain
point that I feel viscerally and I'm
going to write to that and then when we
sit down at a table and you and I have
done us we write a speech we write a
talk and we run it by some people if you
don't laugh at the table
they're not going to laugh in front of 3
000 people right if the room doesn't
feel it so
what if DJ you sat back and said wait a
minute there's a whole swath of people
who are frustrated that the traditional
life paths don't work I'm gonna serve
people in that moment because I'm
feeling that pain right I'm not going to
imagine somebody else's situation I'm
going to start addressing what's going
on to me and you know how easy it is to
start a YouTube channel now how easy it
is to get in your local area and start
meeting with Folks at coffee shops and
you begin to hear from them you and I
test content in similar ways so DJ I
want you to go back Ken just said it go
back to the people you want to help and
put yourself in contact with the people
you want to help and by the way running
out of time yeah I've told this story a
million times but my mom got her first
took her first community college class
at 42 and took one the next semester one
class one class the next semester
graduated with her PhD at 57 and got
tenured as a professor at 62 and she's
in her 70s and she just told me the
other day hey I'm teaching at Oxford all
next summer if you want to bring the
kids over as though it's like down the
street right so there's no such thing as
too late get after it get after it get
after it yeah I you know DJ I would tell
you that I uh made a total life change
at the age of 33 and really tiptoed into
34 to say I'm actually going to go after
broadcasting I had no experience no
degree and it took me
seven years to step into the dream job
to get into broadcasting and I can't
tell you how many people told me I was
too old they're like dude listen you got
some talent but you you missed the boat
you're 33 you're 34. nobody gets into
broadcasting that age and that's
probably true
um but I was just stubborn enough or
delusional enough you pick the adjective
to stay with it but I can tell you on
the other side it's not too late and
that lie is a Lie from the pit of Hell
that my ship has sailed and that's the
voice of doubt and and can I just tell
you John I realized this recently you
and I get a lot of similar type
questions different topics but the root
of what is going on underneath of it is
usually the same and I found that
fear and doubt are two of the biggest
enemies to progress in any area of our
life
but fear and doubt only show up for
people who are trying or longing yeah
the people who sit on the bleach is a
life I find don't have any fear and
doubt nope because they're just sitting
there watching everybody else with their
elbow deep in a bag of popcorn you know
they get through life through
complaining and blaming right yeah but
people who who face fear and doubt who
experience it they're in the arena
you're in it yeah you're in there and
that's a good sign yes that you're
Longing To be or to do
um and that you're striving and you're
making some progress so I just I just
wanted to throw that in there John
because I I feel that the the
discouragement is so heavy that means
you care and I would just want people to
go if you're facing doubt and you're
facing fear there's another narrative
there
because sometimes fear and doubt John
protect us absolutely if if if I say you
know to you hey John I'm uh I'm gonna
I'm gonna go dunk a basketball tonight
at the YMCA and and you go really and I
start to have some doubt that's doubt
protecting me from humiliation because I
can't touch the net right right but if I
doubt that I can't be a good dad or a
good father here oh now that's fear
holding me back excuse me doubt holding
me back that's coming from an unhealthy
place you experience this with callers
all the time absolutely but I would I
would tell you if you fear of being a
good dad that means you that means you
care about it yeah it means it matters
yeah you're invested and so exactly
right I want people not to be so
debilitated by fear and doubt because
that's usually a good sign yeah when
there's fear and doubt lean into it it's
only one way and it's through it all
right that's true there's only one way
that's through it and hey that guy he
really did write that you that you two
were he wrote that question specifically
for YouTube because you're literally his
favorite person
and we love that we don't get a lot of
compliments James never tells us
anything positive so seriously just
beating us down don't take the
affirmation all day long and I paid the
guy 20 bucks but he still wrote it
we'll be right back on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsay to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm John deloney
joined here by Ken Coleman and
we've got a beautiful couple on the debt
free stage Sam and Nikki on the Ramsey
solution debt free stage how are you we
are doing well thank you
better than I deserve well he has voices
as well that's exciting all right where
are you where are y'all visiting us from
Southern California So Cal how much did
you pay off 127 000 and some change 127
000 and you had to do it while paying
Southern California taxes man it was
painful thank you yes how long did it
take uh four years four and a half years
four and a half years and what's your
range of income during this time it
started in the low 30s and it ended at
about 140 000. what excellent what do
you do for a living uh three jobs day
job in marketing night job as an Adjunct
professor of English at the Masters
University and another night job as a
staff writer for the Babylon bee oh what
wait a second all right I gotta fan out
a little bit so the Babylon B for for
maybe folks who don't know you give us
the description of Babylon B Christian
news satire news satire is a subset of
satire yeah Christian news satire is
what it sounds like all right so John
this is great because we have a Babylon
B article here I've got to read just a
little excerpt because of the work you
all do it's so funny the headline was
Biden calls Dave Ramsey's radio show for
advice on paying off 31 trillion this
was yours right correct I'm gonna brag
on you really quick uh so for our
listener viewer hang with us this is
this is uh Sam's work here okay this is
from this set tirical or listen to me
satirical article here we go at first
the call had proceeded according to
Ramsay's normal rhythm of uncovering
asking probing questions followed by
targeted recommendations for reaching
Financial Freedom things derailed ever
caller elaborated on what had
folks the caller is Joe Biden owning up
to spending six trillion dollars per
year while making only four trillion
dollars per year causing Ramsey to
explode you spent two trillion more than
you make you got a freaking credit card
from China what the heck is wrong with
you the caller Joe Biden had tried to
interject excuses blaming Mega
Republicans and deer-wearing Kevlar
vests and corn pop but Ramsay was having
none of it he bellowed into his headset
you need to buy a lot of envelopes for
these trillions because you have been
living dumb d-u-m-b dumb you nailed our
boss so there it is well well done we'll
do a lot of hours to catch the voice yes
you got it I gotta tell you and uh boy
wouldn't that be a fun call if that ever
happened in real life okay hey what
happened how did you get how'd you get
involved with this weird gang that we
run here what happened we remember like
it we remember it like it was yesterday
we were dead Dave Ramsey adjacent for a
year and then driving one day we had
made a habit of listening to the podcast
he started yelling at us he started
ranting and raving about stopping the
Dave ramsey-ish method he said go full
Dave Ramsey or do nothing we realized we
had been piddling along and only half
doing it we got serious within the week
but it worked
so
um
what was going on in your lives that you
thought we got to get out of debt here
we just wanted to honor the Lord with
our resources we weren't being good
stewards of our money we it was going in
and out a faster
than we thought it was and so we really
wanted to honor the Lord and after Dave
Ramsey Dave's shouting at us it just
really turned a corner what kind of debt
was it it's a student at about 60 grand
for my student debt from a master's
degree about 60 Grand from her for her
undergrad okay wow all student debt what
was the I mean obviously the multiple
jobs okay that was a lot of effort give
us some of the maybe extreme choices or
big time sacrifices did you actually
rice and bean it I mean what did that
look like for you guys to make this kind
of a dent in in four and a half years
well by God's grace he's given us
um four kids in five years wow and at
one point we were living in an apartment
a one-bedroom apartment with three kids
in the closet and I worked from home I'd
have to keep them at Bay during my zoom
calls yeah so we had three toddlers in a
closet in our one bedroom apartment on
behalf of the mental health
practitioners of America we thank you
because it's gonna be incredible
redefining anxiety 20 20 years from now
yeah I think you guys should write a
book on redefining patience exactly I
don't even know how you did that she is
a stay-at-home mom and she's the world's
best couldn't have done it without her
oh wow so what was your
I think back to those moments and now
you look back and you're experiencing
Financial Freedom you'll you'll look
back and think man we did it we did we
did it
um
what was the hardest part of this
there's got to be some dark moments you
got three people like this isn't what
you drew up in your head this isn't why
you went to grad school this isn't what
you dreamed for your four kids take us
back to the darker moments
um it had to do with watching the
interest payments rack up and see that
they weren't going anywhere that was one
impetus yeah definitely and we knew that
we wanted to give our kids a room I
think that was a fire under us we wanted
to make sure that they grew up with a
backyard that we just got out of there
as fast as we could even though we loved
it and we were so grateful for our cozy
few years together real close but um
yeah it was definitely a sacrifice where
does this y'all have a very unique
disposition
y'all have chosen to look at the world
as a series of challenges yeah that
we're going to overcome and it stinks
but that's part of life and we're going
to make our where does that disposition
come from that's something that the
world is lacking in a profound measure
Romans chapter 8 uh all creation is
groaning together for Redemption we we
believe we live in a fallen World which
really is a negative Universe with a lot
of friction that you've got to be
prepared for um the word of God prepares
you for it if you live by it Faithfully
yeah suffering produces perseverance and
perseverance
endurance and endurance hope
so every time a challenge gets laid in
front of you you you're you instantly go
to there's gonna be light at the end of
this let's go do it the gospel frees us
from this continuous negative ebb and
flow and descent into tragedy you know
we have hope now because of Jesus we
consider it all joy when we fall into
various trials because we know that the
testing of our faith produces
steadfastness and steadfastness has its
work in us and we can be perfect and
complete lacking in nothing on the other
end
wow I'm ready to take an offering right
uh if we could get James to play on the
keyboard I can take it shortly after uh
fantastic after William Wallace yells
Freedom we're gonna yeah that's awesome
so working as a couple obviously we're
seeing tremendous teamwork that we've
already heard a little bit about what
would you say to other couples uh not
just couples but people that are on this
journey whether they're in the beginning
of the journey they're Midway through
what is the key to finishing this
journey get on the same page about it
and then talk to other people about it
so they are built-in accountability
um my parents were actually able to help
us a little bit during the process her
parents were supportive we had a lot of
cheerleaders but it all started with
making sure we were both fully aligned
with going full Dave Ramsey not Dave
ramsey-ish what was it like making 140
000 and not having the lifestyle to show
forward people give you a hard time
about it did you have to deal with your
fair share of in Southern California of
oh honey right did you have to do with
that you know what it's I feel like it's
feaster famine with the real estate in
Southern California so everyone kind of
lives if we're below making below you
know a certain amount of money everyone
lives in an apartment and so it was just
normal for us but
um we we budget a lot so we still try
now that we're debt free we really try
to have fun with the kids and you know
take trips to out of state and do road
trips so we talk a lot about peace and
Dave and I several of us have talked
about I don't even know if we have a
picture of Peace anymore that's just
become it's become a mythological word
what is the piece you're experiencing be
very specific you just mentioned we get
to go play with the kids what are some
other things some tangible pictures of
peace that have emerged in your home
since you've become debt free
we've got a Finish Line that we've now
passed which has caused us to
re-evaluate our next Finish Line and we
didn't kind of start scrambling around
blindly we went back to the word we went
back to the Bible our finish line now is
stewardship ongoing stewardship for the
purpose of investing and giving and
setting our children up for success
so peace looks like you all get to
decide what happens next in your life
right yep beautiful beautiful beautiful
well Sam and Nikki from Southern
California paid off 127 thousand dollars
in four and a half years making thirty
thousand bucks to a hundred and forty
thousand dollars and you're officially
debt free count them down let's hear
your debt free scream
three two one we're set free
[Applause]
you don't see that attitude very often
what that's an inspirational attitude
you two I love it I love it I love it
Sam and Nicki can do it you can to
America
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show it's got to
Adrian in Monterey California what's up
Adrian
hey um how you guys doing excellent
excellent how are you
I'm amazing I'm really excited to be on
the show thank you here so much you got
it what's up
okay so here's my question
um I'm currently in baby step one I've
got all my my uh totals ordered out and
everything on how much I have a 2600 in
credit cards I have I'm currently
leasing a car that's the biggest thing I
need to figure out what to do with
um I leave it a few months back
um a little bit negative in it but the
buyout is 18 000 I currently have 14 000
left on it and I don't know if I should
pay it down to where I can just sell it
back to them and have and you know save
up a little bit more money to go buy a
car for cash
or if I should just pay this down and I
maybe potentially buy it out at the end
with cash and just keep this you know
because obviously it's a newer car
um just there's a few ways I can go
about it I'm not sure exactly what I
should do what's the most economical for
me
well I mean just have you run the
numbers on it what is more economical
for you
well
I mean I I don't know exactly how much
it's worth yet because I haven't gone
and actually got it appraised again last
time I did it was worth about 26 I think
but it might be lower now because you
know the prices and everything are
fluctuating
oh hold on here's what I would do I
would go ask for the
payoff amount and sometimes you can just
go online and click a button for what's
the what's the buy out of this leasing
or it's in your contract what's the
buyout of this lease and then I would
get on Kelly Blue book and find out what
that car is going for in the private
Market
and if you can sell it sell it and pay
it off if you can uh if you look and say
I want to keep keep this car so I'm
going to take out a loan I actually
would take out a loan of some difference
and
let me go to one of the options that you
laid out I think it was the first one
um you said you could pay it down
and then sell it back to them what would
that would give me the numbers behind
that transaction
I think it would possibly I don't know
exactly would have to know how much I
how much it's worth exactly to them but
I am assuming it's going to be around
maybe I'm estimating 6 000 probably last
time I checked and then I would need to
you know save up an extra 2000 to buy a
car for cash
so they would 6 000 is what they they
would buy it from me for no no no I mean
the difference between
um difference yeah so okay well so
here's the challenge John and I can't
really give you clear advice because you
don't know the value of the car but I
think all the options you listed
uh you just got to go with the one
that's best for you you know so if
paying it down let's say you pay it down
you get after for two or three months
and that allows you to get to a good
position a positive position and sell it
back to them great or if it's a better
Financial play to sell it private seller
then do that or if you go to a credit
union get a five thousand dollar loan
and pay the three thousand dollar
difference difference and go take a two
thousand dollar that two thousand
dollars that's left and go buy yourself
a hunk of junk you've just improved your
net debt
um ratio significantly okay
and we're not in the business to tell
people to get loans but if it gets you
out of a lease and it takes your total
debt commitment way down then
um go make that move here's what I think
I think you leased that car because you
couldn't afford it but you wanted it in
your driveway and leasing it allowed you
to
get that car with low payments
um I think you still love that car is
that right
I really don't know to be honest I mean
I I would be if it gets me out of debt
I'd be happy to part waves with it I I
like it it is nice
um you know it's a 2022 Altima it's a
nice car but at the end of the day I
know I can live without it okay so I
mean it's you're right it's nice and
you're broke
right exactly yeah let's choose safety
let's solve for Freedom over solve for
shiny depreciating asset in the driveway
okay does it sound good that sounds
great I'm gonna figure out a way to get
out of it
um and then go give me a card for cash
and then get on baby step three one
because sometimes I'm done with this
there you go man I love it I love it I
love it I mean nobody loves an Ultima I
mean some people do really yeah love
it's a strong word John it is love my
wife still talks so fondly of her
Corolla like with all of her heart yeah
it's fond I don't know if it's love no
it's love I don't think so I think you
can love I'm you know I'm not trying to
bang on our friends over at Nissan but
all right let's go to Angelina it's
keeping it real here London England
what's up Angelina
hello hi yes Angelina yes thanks Michael
really nice to meet you guys I listen to
you every morning oh lovely that's
wonderful yeah directly in your phone it
kind of changed my life
um can you can you hear me uh see if you
can move the phone uh a little bit
um anxiety better a little bit better
there a little bit better yeah a little
bit okay all right go for it what's up
yes
I've been there for 16 years I love what
I've joined Myself by working a god
Human Resources they are offering an
opportunity for the old staff to
voluntary totally resigned and to me
that would work out about 40
000 pound locked um that would be like
10 years expenses for me
um to start from and I'm just wondering
if this is a wise decision to take up
the opportunity I'm on baby step two
nearly at the end like we're living in a
couple of months I'll be there and I
really would like a deposit for a home
and my emergency fund and I think this
would help a lot do you feel confident
do you feel confident Angelina that you
would be able to step in into other
employment because I'm presuming you
still need to work and make an income
correct
yeah I saw the single mom I've been a
single month about three four years now
and so yes do you need to to get into a
role quite quickly and
um I'm confident like a girl because
there's a lot of HR opportunities
Outback
um and I've been thinking about moving
for a while so yeah
so to folks listening um I know there's
some a little bit of static on the line
um Angelina let me recap this um you
work at a university and they're
offering out what's essentially an early
buyout if you retire they'll pay you a
large sum of money to leave and they're
going to put in your account you're
going to high-five them but you're gonna
not have a job and so this large sum of
money looks very attractive to you
you're in baby step two you're tired of
working here you're a single mom for
three or four years you're ready to move
you're thinking about other things
um here's what I want you to do is I
want you to get somebody with wisdom
that you trust
because here's what I'm hearing in your
in your heart and by the way my mom just
went through this
um every University in the world that I
know of is having some sort of buyout
opportunity for folks because they've
got too many staff too many faculty
um yes you are this is an emotional
moment
and there is this is heavily a math
problem
okay yeah can you afford to make this
move
it looks so attractive it'll pay off
your baby step too it'll help you get an
emergency fund it might even help you
move
and then what right so I want you to get
somebody that you trust to sit with you
and to go through the numbers if you
have
um a financial advisor there in London
that you trust or you have a friend who
will look at the numbers with you
impassionately because if you call us
and said hey I'm ready to change out of
this job I want to take get a new job
Ken would walk you through are you ready
to jump and quit and go do something
else except this could be a great
launching pad into something else
but man is Ken you're the one who taught
me don't jump off the dock until there's
another boat there to get on to yeah I I
Angelina I don't want you to take this
and then then try to find something uh I
would try to match up right now yeah I
would start today and we want to match
the timing of it are they giving you a
timeline if you were to accept their
offer uh would there be a date by which
they said okay now this is in effect
yes so that would be July because the
love thing is July of 2023. okay great
so in this case uh yeah I think you got
enough time to find a job but I'd start
today like it was next week yeah you had
to have the job we don't want to wait
until June and not to say that you were
planning to do that so yeah in this case
you were planning to leave anyway you
wanted to leave I'd do it but I'd get
that other job lined up well in advance
of July I love it hey it's another hour
in the books on the Ramsay show stay
with us we'll be right back
foreign
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsey show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life your work your relationships your
mental health and your money I'm John
deloney joined here by Ken Coleman we're
taking your calls on just about
everything the call is toll-free and
it's probably about what the advice is
worth triple eight eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go out to Teresa
and Des Moines in Des Moines Iowa what's
up Teresa
hi thank you very much for taking my
call you got it what's up how can we
help hi I am a 56 year old female and I
am single and I've been single since
2003 so I pretty much raised my three
children went through school became an
RN a registered nurse got my BSN I was a
debt free with college then I went back
to get my DSN and graduated or excuse me
my Master's and graduated in
2013 and had 85 000 worth of student
loan debt so
yeah yeah I wish I would have heard
about you guys a long time ago so I feel
like I'm a little bit
um
um behind
um just for the divorce and being a
single mom it was really hard to save I
worked two jobs and being a nurse I mean
it's I did what I could but my question
is right now so last probably 14 months
ago I just said I'm gonna go work I'm
gonna work work
so I worked probably six to seven twelve
hour shifts a week for 45 days in a row
and so all I've been doing is working
for the past year
so I went from 110 to like 250
000. wow
yeah super excited but don't screw with
a single mama with a goal in mind right
that's right now we're very strong women
that's right yeah and that's how I raise
my kids to a pretty strong good kids so
my question is is pay the student loans
off
and I have a house that is worth like
210 to 220 000. I owe like a hundred
thousand on it
so I'm wondering I've got the student
loans paid now
and so what do I do I have a four
percent which I don't have a 15 I have a
30 year which I know but I have been
paying like 10 000 extra a month pay it
off this year
so just go ahead and pay it off okay
because I've been meeting with my
financial advisor
well I never got but one thing that I
want to step in really quick because I
didn't feel like there was a there was
an either or here so should I what so
what was the other side of this question
wow he feels like since I have four
percent that I should be
um putting more money away in like
mutual funds because I do have a 401k as
a traditional Roth and I have
a um
a Roth IRA so what so pardon me there
are a lot of numbers and I was trying
hard to pay attention no I'm sorry do
you have any debt other than your house
right now
here I just got out of everything I just
worked okay and so so you are you are
working on baby step six paying off a
house that's the baby step that you're
in correct
currents okay and so and what your
advisor is is saying pay the minimum on
your house and put as much money as you
can in your Investments because your
house note is at a four percent interest
rate
and your advisor can make more money
right with you putting more money in the
market so of course here's a financial
interest in you putting money in the
market yeah so no you you walk to walk
the baby steps
and then put every other Penny on your
house get that house paid off because
here's what we're looking for we're
solving for freedom
all right we're solving for no other
liabilities do what I have 100
in liquid cash in the bank so that's why
I'm not understanding okay hold on all
right so we're gonna said that I'm
behind no and so okay Teresa I'm sure
your financial advisor is a good dude
but we're gonna stop listening to him he
didn't get a vote anymore he didn't find
a new advisor so do you believe in them
okay so do you believe in the baby steps
right you've been walking them to the
best of your ability
all right so listen you shouldn't have a
160 000 in cash you should have in your
emergency fund three to six months
whatever that number is if you want six
months six months is good so let's just
walk through this what is six months of
your household expenses what's that
number minus a mortgage actually 30
000 put away for that so you're telling
me you have 160 above and beyond the
thirty thousand
correct are you keeping your mortgage
because it feels snuggly does it you
like it no no because this is what he's
talking about
John she's got bad advice
hemorrhoids pay it off pay it off pay it
off while I get John a tube of
Preparation H let's focus on what you do
today what's your terrible advice is you
stop listening to your financial advisor
how much is the house mortgage what's
left on it 100 Grand there's a hundred
on it and it's worth two times listen
listen
I want you to pay a hundred grand today
today
like okay like put her on put her on
I've just put her on hold here's the
deal you need to call your your mortgage
company transfer the money all right
you're free and clear before dinner yes
my gosh all right now you still got 60.
I want your neighbors asking why is
Teresa doing somersaults in the front
yard can you show anybody anything and
then you should fire your financial
advisor and go to ramseysolutions.com
and get one of our trusted Ramsay Pros
okay and they will help you with what to
do with the 60 above and beyond the
emergency fund invest that you are debt
free your baby step seven before dinner
time and financial advisors
congratulations you can work a 10 key
it's so fun to push buttons on the
calculator and show somebody well if the
return is this [ __ ] you're talking to a
single mom who's busted her butt for the
last 20 years yeah and you're like you
know what you're behind hold on you're
gonna you're failing give me your money
I'll make it okay for you yeah dude you
know what I'd like to do if you get
hemorrhoids listen man right in the
throat right in the Adam's apple boom
I'm not gonna hit anybody I just well
keep your insides well you don't want
him rights either it's metaphorical it
is it's a metaphorical listen man for
freedom I don't care what your APR is
you want to be 65 years old and have no
liabilities
that if your job goes away if you're
unable to work if if yes we want a
retirement we're going to build that up
we're going to put 15 in we're going to
put 15 in
and the stock market's on sale great
you're gonna have 60 000 to figure out
how to how to put in that thing
but have no payments
have freedom for the first time in 20
years you work too hard
to have a bank telling you what to do
with your life you know God Almighty get
a new financial advisor should be
ashamed of yourself dude I'll be right
back yeah John's gonna get to the
pharmacy we'll be back in a minute
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey show every time you
hear someone do their debt-free Scream
on the show it's because at some point
they said I've had it I'm not living
like this anymore and when you get mad
like that you do what they did your life
will change too and right now inflation
and credit cards all of it it's killing
you you've been led to believe that
you're not in control of your money
wrong you have to decide to control what
you can control and that's you your
thoughts and your actions you have the
power to change your future and
Financial Peace University will show you
how this course will teach you the
proven step-by-step plan that's helped
nearly 10 million people beat debt
Master budgeting and build wealth and
you can do it too stop letting debt and
money stress control your life say I've
had it and take back your control Start
Finance Peace University at
ramseysolutions.com FPU that's
ramsesolutions.com
FPU all right let's go out to Rachel in
Pittsburgh what's up Rachel
hey guys thanks so much for taking my
call you got it what's up how can we
help
um I wanted to ask you guys about baby
step six
um hey Rachel talk directly talk
directly into your phone for me
is this any better perfect yes okay
awesome sorry
I wanted to ask you guys about baby step
six
um right now my husband and I are
working through four five and six
um and we have a two-year-old son I
would really love
um to be able to be a stay-at-home mom
with them and grow my business a little
bit more but right now the the finances
are just not working out to make make
that possible so I was wanted to reach
out to you guys because I've been doing
on it and see if you saw any other
options there we're both Engineers we
bring in about 220 before taxes
and we have about 390 left on our house
to pay off so we were originally
thinking that we could uh you know go
gazelle intense on the house for five
years and knock it out but we just
starting to feel like I'm running out of
time to spend with my son yeah are are
the
are the plans uh the the numbers not
adding up or is the vision you had for
that money not going according to plan
those are two different things
so I hear 220 000. that's a really good
income okay
and so what do you mean the the numbers
don't add up to where you could go home
be with your son and kind of grow what
I'm hearing is like a side hustle now is
that correct
correct okay so so that's what John's
asking
if we went down to just one income my
husband's income
um we'd be at you know five grand a
month coming in after taxes and after
retirement and our mortgage is 3 400 if
we're paying on the 15-year okay we have
a 30-year but we're just paying an extra
so how much do you make out of the 220.
110 we're pretty much split down the
middle okay
well
um what is the side hustle what is it
what is that business
[Music]
any little business
um where I'm a farmer florist and I grow
flowers for bouquets and do wedding work
in the summer time
um last this past summer we had a short
season since we moved only about four
months but I was able to bring in uh 15
grand in Revenue probably around eight
grand in profit so not not a whole lot
of money but I definitely have lots of
ideas and think I could grow it if I had
some more time at home and mental
capacity and then and then what's the
payoff date on the house if you guys
stayed as is and you kept working what
would what would be the anticipated
payoff of the home
I think um if we went get Valentine's on
it it would be five years is what we're
coming up with on paper how old is your
son
two
oh yeah
um
John I mean here's what I think Rachel
we got these false narratives yeah
you've boxed yourself into an either or
situation
definitely you said you've done two
things you've boxed yourself into either
this or that and if it's this I don't
see my son until he's seven
and then he's only got oh gosh 11 more
years and he goes to college and my son
is gone that's that's one story you're
telling yourself right the other story
is I think you're tired of being an
engineer
and you don't have an off ramp you've
been working your butt off to be a
incredible woman in stem and you don't
have an off-ramp yep
and can I and that's absolutely right
that's John you nailed it that's what
I'm appearance of false in here so I'm
gonna throw a scenario out at you I'm
not suggesting it but I'm curious how
you'll react okay
so the issue for you not coming home to
do what you really want to do
uh you know try to grow the side hustle
be with your son and John's pointed out
you're already exhausted at what you're
doing is the mortgage payment
that's that's the hurdle I was gonna say
the third party is fixed for that yeah
you guys have decent equity in the house
correct how much
uh we just just moved a year ago um we
had about 160 inequity
yeah
okay well we have a lot of land is part
of it too so so here's here's what
you've done Rachel downsize yeah house I
I I I I you create a world you can't
afford yeah so for me what's most
important is what I'm hearing John
correct me if I'm wrong John's sitting
here with me hearing this but Rachel
what I'm hearing is is that what's most
important is my son and the season with
him
and to kind of do my thing because I'm
already exhausted over here and I'm
exhausting myself all for a house and a
piece of land that to be honest with you
Falls way down the priority chart I'd
sell the house I I would downsize my
life because the only thing keeping you
from doing this is the 3 400 if I heard
that right mortgage payment is that
correct
yeah if it was gone today what would you
do
what to do that because we didn't just
move I'm not telling you to do it I'm
helping you see what you're presenting
to us
as if you have no way out
and I think you do have a way out it
ain't gonna be fun
that's what you you want it all at the
same time yeah you just can't have it
yeah and it's just it doesn't exist and
so we have to grieve one of a few things
we have to grieve the fact and I just
did this and my wife and I are having
this exact conversation different
different Lanes but it has been my dream
to have five to ten acres since I was a
small kid and I want to I finally got it
and I did not know that that meant nine
hours of mowing every other day and I
didn't know that chickens were I just
see this on HDTV they just have chickens
and they just look so nice it looks easy
it's a paint right I didn't know this so
we signed up for a life that now has is
costing us more than we thought not
financially it's costing us more time
more planning when we go out of town I
travel a lot so anyway by the way I'm
not gonna house it your chickens you're
welcome to come over you just can't eat
them they're not that kind but Rachel so
you've created a life that you wanted so
bad and you want to be a stay-at-home
mom and you want to be a six-figure
engineer and you want to have a side
hustle like at some point you're going
to have to grieve the loss of one of
those things to get the life that you
want not all these different goals
you've met the goals you're brilliant
you can do it all and you can't right so
which one of these things do you want to
let go of yeah
and by the way well all of these let gos
are temporary here's the issue Rachel
the answer is if I can answer answer for
you Rachel uh you don't want to give up
any of them uh I I want to give you I
know so here's a theme for you uh amend
everything John said I'm going to give
you a quote from the from the legendary
John Maxwell
uh who once said you got to give up to
go up
and uh he's right and whether that's
relationally
uh financially spiritually emotionally
you have to give up something to make
progress in another area and and John
has put the question before you
and I think you've got to wrestle with
it what matters most and don't wrestle
alone wrestle with your husband that's
why our teammates but you better choose
the most important thing
what you're gonna choose
one more option to what you would think
about hold on let's do this let's do
this stay on the line Rachel we're gonna
roll over to a break and then we will
get to your second question when we get
back
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five we'll
be right back
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey Show triple eight
eight two five five two two five going
back to Pittsburgh to follow up with
Rachel she had a second question on the
back end of her call and we went to
break what's up Rachel what's your next
question
hey John I was just going to ask you
um what you and Ken thought about uh us
piling up some money
um to kind of help with the transition
from building up my side hustle more uh
for a couple years to give us some
margin if if you thought that would be
sustainable or
if if that would be a good option can I
ask you a question about your side
hustle
um and I'm wandering into Ken's
territory here but
anytime somebody says I'm a full-time
engineer
and then they have dreams of just making
floral arrangements for that feels more
reactionary than passionate right so
when you are making floral arrangements
for
um uh weddings or for individuals or for
businesses is this just a response to
the engineering work this is something
you can control creativity you can put
your hands on and you can deliver a
smile to somebody why are you wanted
what is it about the side hustle you
want to invest money in long term
I I just love that I it gives me the
juice as Ken would say
um but I don't don't really get
day-to-day with my office job yeah okay
um listen just real quick because we got
to get to some other calls I I I like
the idea I really do
um I think it's a form of you know we we
have pauses throughout the baby steps
you know for babies and things of that
nature and I think in this case if you
don't want to sell the house and you
guys are going to be there long term
with this land then
stockpiling for the transition it's very
smart move it's going to delay paying
off the house but you can jump right
back on so I don't have a problem on
that no and I think this is a
conversation you sit down and instead of
you and your husband saying okay we have
to do this one or this one turn it into
an adventure and say all right let's
come up with 50 different opportunities
50 different ideas there is no bad idea
let's put them all on the board he can
go get another job you can get a
part-time job you can sell the land you
can move into a condo you can start
throwing everything on the board and
then begin to peel them back
understanding that something has to give
even if it's your picture of I thought I
was going to stay at home and we're
gonna make six figures and we're going
to have this house on this land at some
part of the fairy tale isn't going to
happen in this season of your life it
will at some point it will but just not
today I gotta tell you one of the things
I love is she she used to phrase that I
use a lot on the cake the juice well
that's the answer to your question yeah
is this a reaction is something you feel
deep and so that's that's the phrase if
you got the juice man like you can't
stop thinking about it you want to do it
that's worthy that's pursuing so the key
here is I saw a sign one time Johnny you
just nailed this I saw a sign I was
shopping with Stacy in some store in the
mountains there's a little craft store
those ones that I hate to go into but
you have to yeah
and it said you can have everything you
want just not at the same time yeah very
simple little statement I think that's
what's going on that's right we got to
wrestle through the fact can't have it
all at the same time that's right that's
right all right let's go to Kiara in
Baltimore what's up Kiara
all right so me and my husband
um 22 years old just celebrated our
first year anniversary hey
congratulations
thank you um and so we're on our debt
payoff journey and
um for his line of work he does go out
of work for about two months in December
um and just collects unemployment it is
like technically a layoff though so I
was wondering should we pause
um baby step number two paying off debt
and just save the
um the amount expected for you know
bills and stuff in between now and
December to prepare or I just don't feel
comfortable trying to wait for
unemployment to come through and I just
said good for you good so Kiara I have a
yes and for you okay so I think you save
you pause momentarily and start saving
for that but with the eye on him finding
part-time or what I would call a
part-time full-time job meaning internet
seasonal uh in that season where his his
normal job is not working then he goes
and gets a full-time job that he can
leave at any time and it's just it is
what it is so maybe he's knocking 40
hours out at Target or Walmart is my
point so that we don't have to pause
baby step two and and so I yes and I
like the idea but let's let's start
thinking wait a second what would have
to be true for us not to pause baby step
two and the answer to that is he knows
the seasonal schedule true or false
right yeah so we know Christmas is
coming every year correct
correct so we know that I gotta go get a
job for two or three months every year
yes hey
why does he want to just sit at home for
two months and pause getting out of debt
fix that he'll have some income we just
don't know to what capacity
um yeah well here's a good answer John's
question
here's here's what I'm struggling with
mm-hmm seeing two months of
getting paid I mean being laid off for
seasonal work and not having five jobs
lined up yeah ferociously and also
having another plan to not work a job
where I get laid off every uh for two
months every year
becoming maniacal here's the thing that
I don't know if y'all wrapped your head
around yet y'all are broke
and you're newlywed and this is a scary
season because you're one or two things
going sideways and my promise to you is
they will go sideways whatever they are
you're right on the margin man and this
isn't a time to say all right we're
young and silly let's just we got we got
two months off let's just dude this is
the time to just bust it and set
yourself up so you don't have to you
don't get two months to chill you get
years to chill on the back end of this
you know what I mean
right maniacal work work work get this
debt payoff how much debt do you owe
we owe about 47 000 now we started in
August and we've been able to we just
did our update and it was 52 000 and now
we're down to 47. hey cool you're
getting after it crushing it we've been
moving yes okay let's get maniacal Wild
so you can sit down and say honey I've
got some good news for you guess what
you're not doing for those two months
taking any time off in fact you're going
to get two jobs plus three you don't
want to drive oh that's that that's a
that's a choice for a future husband
because this husband has 47 000 in debt
we gotta pay off this just isn't the
season for I don't I don't feel like
you're right get after it here's the
mindset switch here Kira you guys have
to go from instead of saying well we
have two months where he's laid off
should we pause the baby steps instead
of going in those two months where I'm
off from my regular job
how much money can I make two months
twelve thousand dollars let's go crazy
yeah like change the entire focus of the
two months to go all right now I can go
work three jobs because I could tell
those folks hey sorry it's seasonal if
you want me back next year I'll be here
but if not Deuces yep I'm out I go back
to my job it's a it's a mindset between
this is a Sprint as John said and those
two months aren't a well I don't know
what I'm gonna do and it's too much of
ferocious as John said maniacal activity
and then and now we're getting ahead I
love that idea with let's let's set a
short-term Sprint goal right let's do
ten thousand dollars let's in the into
two months let's be down to thirty seven
thousand yeah let's just get after it
yeah in momentum just Builds on itself
it's uh it's it's a fun thing but I
appreciate the calling congratulations
hey one year in uh the first year
anniversary that's always a big
milestone and wishing the best for you
guys in your marriage all right John if
uh if I could offer people uh Direction
and clear 30 to a a career that is
fulfilling meaning they're they're doing
something they're good at they're doing
something they love and they're creating
results that matter all for ten dollars
would that be a good deal
it's a great deal it's a great deal dude
you made me nervous for a second no he
was thinking about that I'm thinking
golly dude it's a good you get paid off
of these well you sure are putting that
low well I have I have a bone to pick
with Dave on this one but uh we have
offered the get clear career assessment
our assessment we've sold it to tens and
tens of thousands of people it's a 30
product and now in the month of October
at ramseysolutions.com it's available
for only 10 bucks takes 20 minutes
you're gonna get a detailed report on
what you're really good at in work what
work you really love to do and then what
motivates you imagine you put all three
of those together you get some real
purpose and Direction you can get it now
the get clear career assessment ten
dollars it's not gonna last long
ramseysolutions.com and for those of you
who are planning your New Year's
resolution
this is a good place to start now two
months out
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
today's scripture of the day is Psalm 34
4-5 I sought the Lord and he answered me
and delivered me from all my fears those
who look to him are radiant and their
faces shall never be ashamed Chuck
Norris says running from your fear can
be more painful than facing it For
Better or Worse
nothing like a good Chuck Norris I was
gonna say easy for Chuck to say Walker
Texas Ranger's not afraid of anybody I
know he doesn't do push-ups he pushes
the Earth down
this is like a whole bunch of those out
there it's a it's a sub genre yes you
know it's funny I never actually saw one
episode of Walker Texas Ranger I like
old school Chuck like old school Chuck
like from his you know actually action
films no nothing took on a whole Persona
with that show I do there's something
about wearing jeans and a button-up and
a cowboy hat and doing karate it's
incredible So speaking of Texas listen
that's the hard-hitting content you get
on this show do us a huge favor yeah
um yeah so you want more of that you
want more breakdowns of Chuck Norris and
his TV characters now here's the deal
um every show is out there asking you to
buy stuff we're always asking you to hey
come to our Live Events by FPU not
everybody's in a position to do that but
if this show has helped play a role in
your money transformation and healing
your marriage helping you find work that
matters here's a way you can help other
people get that same info by buying
nothing all we ask you to do is hit
subscribe all we ask you to do oh
whether it's podcaster on YouTube please
leave a five star review letting folks
know hey this is a good show it helps
kick the show up into the algorithm and
it gets it into the hands of more people
Sheriff okay share with your friend
that's right if somebody says I can't I
can't I can't afford them the episode
that you're listening to that inspired
you and say yes you can yeah you can
um yeah please leave your reviews and
your five star reviews and subscribe all
right let's go out to Chicago and talk
to Lair what's up Claire
hi thanks for taking my call you got it
what's up
well I'm calling because
um I've recently come into the Dave
Ramsey kind of Clan welcome to the gang
my husband and I are debt free
um but we're kind of slowly trying to
work through the baby's depths
um so we're on we're really blessed I
think already like stepped again because
I'm kind of still learning step five or
six um we just had a son about a few
months ago
um we've already got a 529 plan started
for him so it's already contributing 15
to our retirement fund and you're all
you're all in all in all in we are all
in all and already we've got the three
to six months savings one thousand
dollar savings all good there awesome my
question yeah my question for you today
is just about our savings accounts we've
got multiple types of savings you know
one for car one for travel one for house
plus our three to six months and the
1000 emergency and you know just the
checking account so I don't know if we
should really kind of be focusing all of
our state savings taking it all out of
those and putting it towards the
mortgage we do have in addition to our
savings account
we have you know the Ross we both have
roths plus our um our retirements
through work so just was wondering if
maybe we should also take a um we have
about 14
000 in a savings through
um that we're investing right now and
didn't know if we should be putting that
towards a mortgage and everything else
we have towards those from those other
small savings accounts for house for car
emergencies okay here's what here's what
I hear okay tell me if I'm wrong
you and your husband went bananas
b-a-n-a-n-a-s
y'all went for it and there was a lot of
energy and a lot of like y'all were
going going and then you were debt free
and you didn't know what to do with all
that unused energy and so you created
chaos
now you've got 14 different accounts
doing 14 different things you're still
following the plan but you're you're
trying to keep that adrenaline going by
making your life way more complicated
than it needs to be
do y'all need a new car in the next two
to three years
okay then I would not have a car fund um
are y'all saving up to buy a house
nope I already have a house with
everything done except for the mortgage
there you go so see what I I would maybe
have uh like George and I disagree on
this and that's fine it's just how our
households run George Campbell has his
emergency fund in an online savings
account okay a high yield savings
account I have mine in my same checking
account I just don't I don't mess with
it and it just is a line item like it's
a it's a special account underneath my
master checking account okay
um I would get rid of all of these
different accounts and all these
different banks and consolidate your
money and let your money do one or two
or three things at a time not 15. so
you're putting your 15 into retirement
you're going to pay your house down and
you're gonna put a little bit of money
into the 529 every month and that's it
and what y'all are gonna have to do is
learn how to live and love your life not
running from the lion that's chasing you
you see what I'm saying
yep nope certainly do am I right so just
kind of yeah yeah okay um simplify at
some point you can become addicted to
the adrenaline and the cortisol
and you're probably also somebody who
has imaginary conversations with people
that you're never gonna fight with but
you have it in your head and you win
every one of them and your husband
probably has a bunch of spreadsheets and
schemes implant right am I right
okay yeah reverse it and he's the one
having imaginary conversations I'll tell
my boss you're not gonna tell your boss
anything you're never gonna so stop
spitting yourselves up
simplify simplify simplify now it's
about peace
now it's a life that we can smile and
enjoy and kick our feet up because of
the hard work that we've done see what
I'm saying yeah let's make a plan to get
this mortgage paid off and the way you
guys are so far ahead of everybody
um you all are going to be fine
financially just keep investing your 15
keep putting some money in the 529 and
get that house paid off is that cool
sounds great simplify simplify simplify
you are way ahead of the curve again
what do you got
you got it I think you did it all right
let's go to Zane in Boulder Colorado hey
Zane what's up man
Mr Coleman Dr D how you guys doing today
we are rocking on to the break of dawn
my brother how can we help
well I'm thinking about dropping out of
college and I wanted to get some words
of wisdom okay what are you gonna drop
too
I was thinking about opening my own
business what kind of business
I'd be a blower door verification uh for
residential houses
okay and what is the uh reason that you
want to start that business and thus
you've got to drop out of college to do
it
well my ultimate goal was
to own my own business
um where I'm offering a trusted service
so my
first goal was to finish college and be
a financial advisor okay what changed
uh the school part
I mean also paying for that meaning you
hate it and don't think you need it or
you can't afford it what is the Big
Driver of this
um I could I could probably afford it
it's more of not liking the school part
yeah well I got great news for you you
don't have to have a college diploma to
be a financial advisor now you do have
to get some education in the form of you
know certifications in whatever state by
state requirements are there but you
don't have to have a diploma so I I this
feels reactionary to me and I'm all
following your heart but I don't hear a
lot of heart I hear a head idea that
well I always kind of wanted to work for
myself and this cool thing is not me and
by the way I'm okay with that I I'm I'm
okay with someone going College isn't
for me
but it's not just a feeling it has to be
fact-based and so if you want to be a
financial advisor we wouldn't be
thinking about whatever the services
that you describe that that's not in the
that's an idea just to let me be free
and work for me it's not a good enough
of a reason to drop
now if I drop out to then put my time
and effort into becoming trained and
certified and with an eye on getting to
work for a financial advisor and working
my way up and this is something that I
really really want to do because I see a
sense of mission behind the results of
helping people with their finances I
love coaching and Advising people and I
happen to be pretty good communicator
and go with numbers check check check
I'm okay with that if you asked stay
there until we find the thing you asked
the best oh go ahead dude I just want to
give him the get clear assessment I want
you to take this assessment and figure
out what are we moving to I love that
question where not what are we running
from what are we going to great question
kid hey that wraps up today's show
thanks to Austin Ben James Andrew the
whole gang and thanks to you America for
tuning in we'll catch you next time on
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
co-host of the Ramsey show did you know
over 18 million people listen to the
Ramsey show every week a lot of those
people listen on one of our 600 plus
radio stations across the country to
find a station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]